JENNY MURPHY: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this week's episode,
or session, I guess,
of the Google+ Platform
Office Hours.
This week we're going to be
talking about snippets.
a lot about snippets.
How you can use them, what you
can use them to do, and other
cool tools and stuff.
Joining me is Gus.
GUS: I'm Gus, and this is my
first time on Office Hours.
And I'm pretty new to
the Google+ team
as a developer advocate.
And I'll just be trying to
help Jenny out today.
JENNY MURPHY: And I'm Jenny,
Jenny Murphy, developer,
programs engineer, on the
Google+ platform.
So I spend a lot of time out
there on the Plus page and the
forums helping you guys build
awesome stuff, and snippets
are a part of that.
So we're going to be talking
about those today.
And just one quick note about
our Office Hours, we do love
getting feature requests
from you guys.
So feel free to send those
in and ask us.
But in general, we don't
make comments about
forward-looking things.
So although we'll definitely
take your feedback and note
it, there's just not a lot we
can tell you, especially about
release dates and that
kind of stuff.
But don't let that stop you from
asking us fun questions.
Great.
So I guess we should dig
into the snippets.
GUS: So as someone who's
actually relatively new to
snippets Just getting started,
I kind of would wonder, what
exactly is a snippet?
JENNY MURPHY: That's
a great question.
So a snippet is--
well actually, why would I tell
you, when I can show you?
So let me bring up a quick,
cool, demo of what a snippet
is, and what it allows
you to do.
So here we have a snippet
in action.
So a snippet is a way for you
as a publisher to control.
[INAUDIBLE]
So here we have a snippet of
one of my example sites,
Baking Disasters, as
it appears in a
Google web search result.
And you can see that there's an
image specified, a title,
and a description.
But snippets show up in
a lot of other places.
Let's take a look at
the page itself.
We can see that the snippet is
also used in the share box
when I share the post
on Google+.
Just pull it up here,
and we can see it.
Let's share that.
So if I jump on over to Google+
and reload the page--
the wrong key.
Reload with the reload button.
We can see that the
same snippet
has shown up on Google+.
So snippets are a tool for you
as a content publisher to
control what shows up
all over the place.
And snippets aren't just
used at Google.
If you mark up your content
in the right way, the same
snippet will show up in all
sorts of different places,
including the three top
major search engines.
GUS: So now that we know kind
of what a snippet is
[INAUDIBLE]
a developer care?
JENNY MURPHY: Why would
a developer
care about a snippet?
Well if you don't specify a
snippet on your website,
[INAUDIBLE]
the controls that you
have in here.
We know that you're always going
to tell us what's really
important about your content,
and snippets are how we give
you that control, and how
you can specify that
for the whole world.
GUS: [INAUDIBLE]
some information about
specifically what that crawler
is looking that.
JENNY MURPHY: Exactly.
GUS: OK, so then how
do we use them?
How do we get this snippet
functionality to work inside
of our sites?
JENNY MURPHY: Cool, let's
take a look at that.
We have a lot of cool tools.
Let me switch windows, so I can
show you something neat.
Here we go.
OK, how do you get snippets
into your site?
There are a lot of different
ways to control your snippet.
There's a lot of different
ways to specify
the structured markup.
We have a favorite, we have one
that we like a lot called
schema.org.
Schema.org markup is an open
standard way of marking up the
content that you're publishing,
and it has some
benefit over other techniques.
Schema.org markup is added to
the content of your site,
instead of adding new content.
So you're just marking up
content that's already there,
which saves you a lot of effort
because you don't have
to add anything new.
It's also an extremely
expressive way of specifying
on the structure of your page.
It's not just about a few fields
up top, although there
are a few important ones.
It's a way of specifying the
content of your page for a
whole bunch of different
kinds of schemas.
Everything from recipes, like
the one I showed you earlier
for the macaron on Baking
Disasters to locations.
And even get as specific as my
favorite schema, there's
actually a schema.org schema
for structured markup of
volcanoes, which is
pretty awesome.
But anyway, let me show you some
tools that you can use to
get some snippets onto
your content.
So flip it over here.
You can see we have a little
snippet code generator that
will show you some skeleton code
for adding snippets to
your content.
It's on
developers.google.com/plus.
Once you go there, you can click
around and find it on
under Plug-ins, Snippet, or I'll
be adding a link to it in
the show notes.
So once you get to this page,
the first thing you're going
to do is you're going to tell
us what kind of content your
page has on it.
And we've chosen a few really
common schemas, but you can
specify your own in the other
field if you want.
But let's stick to a
simple one for now.
Local business.
So let's say I'm marking up my
local business for Baking
Disasters which is, I guess,
going into business.
It's not just for example
code anymore.
And let's get an image URL, I
don't actually have one handy,
so I'll use my favorite example
site for links that I
know won't collide with
anyone, example.com.
And this would just be the image
that you want to appear
in the search result, and as
well as wherever else the
snippet will show up.
So in addition to the title
image, you can also specify a
description.
In this exercise I'm just
typing it in, but you'll
probably have content that
correlates to the description
on the page itself, usually
an intro paragraph, or
something like that.
When baking goes all wrong.
GUS: So something I noticed,
Jenny, in the image URL you
used a site that's external
to bakingdisasters.com.
Is that perfectly acceptable
along the way, or is it sort
of a best practice to stick
to the stuff that's
within you're own site?
JENNY MURPHY: So there are
always going to be cases where
your image [INAUDIBLE]
structure and especially
to a lot of you
publishers out there.
So we allow it, but make sure
this is your image.
Make sure that it's something
you control.
Posting it from a domain you
control's important.
So I'm demoing a bad
practice here.
GUS: The last thing you'd want
to happen is for your images
to get switched in your schema
behind your back.
JENNY MURPHY: That would sure
be a shame, wouldn't it.
GUS: OK, really good to know,
just something I was thinking.
JENNY MURPHY: Good question.
GUS: Cool.
JENNY MURPHY: So let's see
what we have here.
So what's happening here is as
I'm filling out these fields,
there's some example schema.org
mark up showing up
in the little pane on
the right side.
And this is a very simple
example of how to do a
schema.org markup to
get you started.
In this case, we're adding an
items scope to the HTML
element of the page, and this
is where we tell whatever's
parsing that structured markup
what kind of content we're
marking up.
And then we've filled out a few
fields here below which
correlate to those text boxes
that I typed stuff into just a
moment ago.
There's the name, there's the
image, and there's the
description.
And this is the basic amount of
markup that you need to get
control over just changing
the image, the title, the
description and Google+,
Google web search, and
everywhere else is processing
this markup.
Yep.
But you can go a lot
deeper than that.
So let's dive into schema.org
a little further.
I showed you a few schema
types here, but there's
actually a whole bunch
more available.
If you just go to aptly-named
schema.org, you can find a
whole hierarchy of different
schemas.
Whenever you use a specific
schema you can also use any of
the different subtypes that
are under it in the tree.
So, let me zoom into
this a little bit.
I do not know what I did.
Let me escape out of here.
I've gotten into an
accessibility mode that I'm
not familiar with.
GUS: Click on the magnifying
glass.
JENNY MURPHY: On the
magnifying glass?
GUS: It's in the left
of your screen.
There you go.
JENNY MURPHY: Ah, it's been a
while since I've used this.
GUS: Just hit right there.
JENNY MURPHY: There we go.
GUS: Close it.
JENNY MURPHY: Close it?
GUS: Save.
JENNY MURPHY: Oh,
thank you Gus.
Saved again.
So here is the schema.org
list of schemas.
Whenever you use a specific
schema-- like we were just
using local business--
there's actually a whole
bunch of different
sub schemas of that.
And you can use that wherever
that would be--
whatever is most specific
to your content.
There's a whole bunch
of cool ones here.
One of my favorites
is tire shop.
So all you tire shops out there
who have pages, or all
of you content producers that
have pages that describe tire
shops, can actually very
specifically describe all the
metadata specific to your tire
shop, which is pretty cool.
And when we arrive on one of
these schemas, we see there's
a whole bunch more fields.
There's the fields at the top,
which are pretty much the same
as the fields that we've filled
out on the tool, but
there's a whole bunch of other
stuff down here below that
describes stuff specific
to our schema.
When you're marking up your
content we recommend that in
addition to the basic fields
that the tool helped you get
started with that you mark
up everything that
you possibly can.
You want to give us as much
detail as possible, because
we're starting to use
that detail in
more and more places.
And there's going to be really
cool stuff that results.
So even if you're marking up a
volcano, and volcano is not a
schema that we do a whole lot
with right now, someday, once
we have volcano aware software,
we might be doing
some really cool stuff with
that particular markup.
[INAUDIBLE]
GUS: --volcanoes everywhere and
do whatever we need to do
in our plus apps.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes, you can
do the best possible
sharing with them.
There's actually one specific
case where we're starting to
use a lot of the more advanced
features [INAUDIBLE]
GUS: Yay, victory.
JENNY MURPHY: --popularly.
Where am I hiding it?
It's in one of these minimized
Windows, I'll find it.
Let me open another one.
Cool.
OK, it came up.
So here's the Google+ history
beta web interface.
So the Google+ history API, as
you may have heard, or may
have not heard, just recently
entered developer preview.
So it's not out for general
availability yet, but it's a
great example of us doing
something cool with schema.org
markup that we weren't
doing before.
It's also an example of where
we're, for the first time,
starting to use a lot of the
other details of the schema
markup that you apply
to your pages to do
more expressive stuff.
So when you create a moment
with a history API, that
[INAUDIBLE]
doesn't really express it much,
there's a potential for
cool stuff to happen here
someday, which is always
pretty awesome.
GUS: Exciting history stuff.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
GUS: We all look forward to
advancements in history.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, it's
an exciting API.
I'm really excited about it.
So let's say you've added a
bunch of schema.org markup to
your pages, which you were going
to ask me about, but I
derailed us a little it.
GUS: So how do we add schema.org
markup to our
pages, Jenny?
JENNY MURPHY: Thank you, Gus.
So I already talked a little bit
about how we add it with
those tools.
Once we've added it, how
do we verify that
it's actually working?
So let's take a trip back to
the Baking Disasters page.
GUS: This says macaron.
I thought it was macaroon, as
opposed to one or the other.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes, I was
actually calling this macaroon
until I went to the party where
we baked it, and I was
fortunate enough that a
professional pastry chef
joined us, who was very helpful
until he got a little
distracted by beer,
and was unable to
help us with our macaroons.
One of the reasons it became
a baking disaster.
Macaron is apparently a more
specific kind [INAUDIBLE]
GUS: --baking disaster
that would create.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah,
I kind of had some
potential for exploding.
You can read more on
Baking Disasters.
Anyway, I've added a
bunch of schema.org
markup to this site.
As I showed you before, if we
want to validate that the
schema.org markup works, the
easiest and most obvious way
is you just go and you hit the
button, and you verify that
the snippet looks correct.
But this only allows you to
verify some of the markup.
We have some more advanced tools
that are pretty cool.
We have the rich snippet
testing tool.
This one's been around
for quite a while.
But it still works, and
it's still great.
So let me copy the URL.
And we can go to this tool,
paste in our URL, or you can
paste in the HTML content, if,
for example, you have a page
that's behind a firewall
right now.
And you can get a report, you
can get a preview of the
snippet as it will appear in
your Google web search result.
And you get a really detailed
breakdown of all the kind of
content we've pulled
out of there.
So in cases where we may opt
to pick one kind of markup
over another, this tool allows
you to see all of it, kind of
like a neat [INAUDIBLE].
So it's a great place
to start, but it can
kind of be a hassle.
So one of the developers on our
team created a new tool.
He made a Chrome extension
that does a
lot of the same stuff.
It's called--
what is it called?
Beta markup, or--
I can't quite see it.
But I'll be mentioning it in
the show notes, micro beta.
GUS: Micro beta.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes, and what
it does is whenever you're
visiting a page you can hit a
button, and you can see an
output of all the schema.org
markup on that page.
So it's a great way, when
surfing around on your site,
to validate the markup is all
happy and presenting the way
you want it to.
Cool.
GUS: I don't have that many
more questions, actually.
You've answered a lot of the
initial reservations and
interest that I had
around schema.
JENNY MURPHY: So you going to
go schema you're site now?
GUS: I'm going to go
schema my site.
JENNY MURPHY: Or have
you already?
GUS: Maybe I already did.
JENNY MURPHY: Maybe
you already did.
GUS: Poorly.
I need to go back and
do it better.
JENNY MURPHY: What are you
going to do better?
GUS: I'm going to make sure that
I'm using all the right
types for my posts and other
things that are on my site.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
OK.
Well that wraps up our kind
of faux interview here.
Thanks Gus.
Now we're going to go and we're
going to answer some of
the questions, if you've asked
any in the forums.
So let's go take a look on the
Google+ developers' page and
see what you guys have been
chatting about while we've
been babbling here.
And I don't really see that many
questions about snippets
or the Google+ platform.
Just one comment about
cameras and mics.
We'll get that worked out.
We're still working
on the studio.
The quality seems a lot better,
but we're still
working out some kinks.
So bear with us during these few
weeks of Office Hours as
we get that stuff all smoothed
out from a technical
perspective.
But it looks like there's not
a lot of conversation about
snippets out there right now,
so I guess we might as well
wrap it up.
Sound good?
GUS: Sounds good.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
So just checking for comments
in other places.
Well, thanks for joining
us, everyone.
So what we did in a quick
recap, we talked about
snippets, what they are, how you
can put them on your site,
and what are the cool stuff that
results from you adding
that markup to your page.
So tune in next week, and we'll
be talking about some
other developer topics.
You'll be able to find our
sessions announced on the
Google+ developers' page a few
days before each session with
the detail topic.
And you can also go to Google
Developers Live, and you can
see several of our sessions
that are upcoming and what
kind of topics might be
of interest to you.
So I guess that's all
we have for today.
GUS: That's all we've got.
JENNY MURPHY: Thanks everyone.
Goodbye.